wow that's a deep question
[Music]
it's funny it's actually like in spanish
but the word is like
and basically what that means is like
good for nothing
and uh
yeah it's just like it's just a mean
thing to tell somebody because
everybody's good at something and uh
yeah i don't believe that anymore
but yeah
it was my mom man and she hurt my
feelings saying that [ __ ] but i don't
know how deep you want this to be
she's different now and she like
apologized for that but
yeah like she said that to me once or
twice many times growing up and i
remember just hearing that word and it
always just like
hurt me in my soul and uh yeah words
definitely have power definitely uh
i believe so
love my mom though look
still love my mom even though she said
something to me um
you gotta forgive when you can
the most hurtful thing that i've been
told was
that it wasn't worth anything
by one of my parents
but being told that you're not worth
anything by one of your parents i think
that that
messes you up mentally
and it sticks with you yeah
so
the most hurtful thing i've been told
i was a nine-year-old
and
i
loved to play guitar and sing and it was
like my favorite thing i was like super
passionate about it was amazing and i
would listen to all my dad's music and
usually it was kat stevens and so just
play the guitar and then i started
singing like moon shadow moon shadow and
there was a woman i heard her walking up
the stairs
um
to i don't know she was selling
something or a church you know like one
of those and she stopped and she was
listening i could see her shadow and so
then she rang the doorbell my dad came
he opened the door and she's like who
has such a beautiful voice my goodness
it's so beautiful she's amazing
and he's like yeah how can i help you
what do you want blah blah blah
and um
you know i was awestruck because the
first time
that um
somebody had actually acknowledged
my voice and my singing
and um
sorry it's been so long and i'm still
carrying the hurt and paint but um
when my dad came back in i said wow that
was so cool like she actually
acknowledged and said how beautiful my
voice sounded he's like no your voice
sounds absolutely horrific you should
never sing
and so i've never see
since then it kind of i can't even
barely talk right now because it stifled
my voice
so
that's the most hurtful thing
so that was the last time you sing
like that
yeah
i do other stuff but singing is hard
and i loved it
i thought i was going to become like a
professional singer
and i'm still stuck at that moment and i
don't know how to like
unstick from that
the most hurtful thing i've ever been
told was by a colleague who told me
right before i started a new job their
advice to me was don't be yourself
and that
i think they were meaning to be honest
uh in in terms of like
you know don't be too bubbly
you want to be professional but
it kind of crushed my soul just a little
bit honestly
um
i don't know my mom used to
tell me all the time that i end up like
my dad not really amount to anything
all the time i don't think my dad's that
bad
and it hurt me to think that someone
thinks like
that my dad is less than what he is and
then thinking that i would amount to
less than what i am
you know
but oh well
do you still carry that hurt with you
uh no pretty much just left everything
behind i mean i'm here in
san diego
away from my hometown left everything
behind i don't even talk to most people
anymore so
i'm over life
starting a new one
um i had my ex stepmother i'm a really
talkative person to have been my whole
life and my ex-stepmother once told me
that i should only say every third thing
that came to my mind and that i should
keep the rest of myself because you
didn't want to hear me talk and it was
something that i think
kept me from
sharing a lot of ideas and feelings that
i've had in my life and in a lot of ways
like kept me to myself
because i was thinking of only speaking
every third thing out loud
i wouldn't say it's necessarily the most
hurtful thing i've been told but more so
the most painful things that i wasn't
told in childhood
um
you know just like
honestly like i love you for my parents
it's as dark as that is um do you have
siblings yeah older brother does he feel
the same
yeah i mean
i still remember
like last year when i hugged him for
like the first time in like so many
years just because we never like hugged
as a family
um
he like looked at his shoes sheepishly
and he's like wow i can't remember the
last time that we hugged and yeah i
don't know love just was never like a
thing that was like shown or used in the
family so definitely it's more so what
the things that hurt the most was the
absence of
of words and acts and whatnot not so
much
hurtful things directly being said
in high school i was at a pool party and
then
after the party i lost my virginity to
this kid and then the next day oh my
hair's curly so after we were swimming
and my hair was white curled up and then
the day after this kid took my virginity
tweeted about me and said i need a girl
that looks good natural no medusa
looking ass that was about me
at the time i was really upset i
straightened my hair every day for like
four years
it was extremely self-conscious and
thought about that literally i mean that
was
like six years ago and i'm still
thinking about it so
yeah it was really hurt my feelings
my teacher in fifth grade told me that i
looked like an ad for a depression
commercial
just out of nowhere we were in class and
he had me stand up in front of the whole
class and was like this is what you look
like sarah and started imitating me
because i have rbf so if i'm not smiling
i
look angry i guess and he started
imitating me and the whole class was
laughing and then he just kept going for
about 15 minutes until i was just left
standing there crying in front of
everybody it only ended because then it
was time for lunch
do you still carry that heartbeat
yeah i feel a lot of the time where if
i'm not smiling or acting a certain way
then people won't want to be around me
um i've been told that i shouldn't be in
a relationship just because i have
issues like with myself but i go to
therapy and i work on myself anyway
i couldn't
i couldn't differentiate whether i
needed more therapy or if i had to stop
going to therapy because it was like
it was like confirming that i was broken
and that i didn't deserve anything
um that i'm was fat ugly and didn't want
to be married to me
no actually it took me longer to break
up with
uh 20 years and six kids it's a little
more than you could just walk away from
something like that
i would say it's more
still a damaging piece in the back of my
mind
i don't think anybody really ever gets
over that uh most hurtful thing is
no one's going to want to be your friend
if you keep acting like that
no one will ever love you if you are
overweight
if tao loses weight she would look so
pretty i don't want to be with you
anymore
oh by the way the the two girls
that you witness to birth they're not
yours
i love you but i don't like you
do you remember who said it my mom how
did you get past it
uh a lot of drugs and then recovery
well when i was a kid i heard my mom
talking about me um
and my artwork and she said she'll never
be an artist
and i was like in kindergarten or first
grade or something and i still remember
that obviously
so yeah and you know what i'm not an
artist she was probably right but it
still was her fault
i was surprised that she
said that because she was an artist
do you carry that pain with you at all
still today uh
only if somebody's talking about art or
drawing not specifically art but just
being artistic i always say i'm not
artistic at all it's probably because my
mom said that
you never know who you might have been i
could be artistic but
you know what i do carry it i guess she
said i wasn't so i still believe that
i'm not
um so in his defense it was probably an
accident but i in high school my
guidance counselor was talking to me
about why a lot of my friends were in ap
classes and i was really curious why i
was the only one in my friend's group of
people of similar coursework who didn't
get these necessary
additional
steps in the right direction towards
college
and when i went to his office and asked
him about it he just looked at me and
said oh
you want to go to college
and it was like this moment of like
well
why why wouldn't i
and like it was like this real like oh
is is it
i wonder if it's me just like what he
sees and
uh well i'm working on my masters now
computer science so it's
i definitely wanted to go to college but
uh
he
definitely immediately pulled out all
the paperwork and stuff and was really
quick to talk about it but in that
moment it's just like
the weight of like oh
i have to like say hi yes i want to be
involved in academia i was like
weird because it was just like something
all my other friends were just like
recommended to
so that that was
it wasn't supposed to be hurtful but man
still to this day does it like i
remember that conversation
when i was in third grade my substitute
teacher asked me whether or not i was in
third grade
because i have dyslexia and
i couldn't read one of the questions
and i asked her what it was said
and you still carry that hurt with you
does it still bother you
kind of it's just
a little hard
you know
i still have just i'm dyslexic and i
can't
it's hard for me to read but i'm better
at reading now
i love you
can you tell us why no i'm not going to
tell you that
okay
but it really spoiled that for me
when i hear i love you
i don't know whether i really believe it
now
it really picked me up
the most hurtful thing was when i was a
little girl growing up in connecticut
the neighborhood kids told me to go back
to my country
how'd that make you feel
confused really yeah
um
yeah mostly just confused like why would
they say that to me i didn't understand
like the the distance that they put me
at i didn't feel it so
do you still carry that hurt with you do
you think
um not really not so much anymore i've
traveled so much and the funny thing was
when i went back to my original country
i didn't fit in there either i was
american so i always felt like in
between worlds
but as an adult i've i've taken the best
of all these worlds and kind of
integrated them into who i am
well the most hurtful thing i've been
told it's been a few but the one that
stuck with me and it still sticks with
me
as when i was two i was burned on the
iron my whole hand came off as a kid so
growing up as a kid and people see my
hand they either say i got oh you have
poop on your hand or oh is something
wrong with you you're alien and even is
30 what 38 now 38 years old it still
bothers me i handicap it i don't ever
let people see it and then i can show
the camera
my hand
so this
it still bothers me to this day so i
always talk like this this hand's
brought up i talk like this so nobody
never sees it because as soon as they do
it's like uh it's something that's
disgusting or it's poop
and that's probably one of the
hurtfulest things i've ever been told
because it still just sticks with me at
38 years old in my life
what do you think can help you
not be so hurt
um to open up to it more and tell my
story because it's a story to tell it's
history behind it you know so now
sometimes with friends as close friends
i'm able to actually deal with it a
little bit more because i try to use it
as a positive thing and say and i turn
it like this and like see but if i turn
it like this it looks like it's a finger
pointing this way
and it does if you look at it
so i try to do that so that's what i'm
working on now and i'm still working on
that at 38 years old in my life
so well thank you for sharing you're so
welcome hopefully expressing it today
maybe helps ease the pain a little bit
definitely would okay
hey everyone for those of you who are
new my name is thoria and i'm the girl
behind the camera make sure to subscribe
and hit the notification bell so you'll
be notified every time i have a new
episode up and follow me on instagram
i'll be posting more on there as always
thank you guys for everything i love you
all and i'll see you next time
[Music]